este vídeo bien podría ser muy
emocionante porque en realidad empezamos
esta idea de lo que son las series de
furia y en realidad es tomando una
función periódica verdad vamos a tratar
de representarla como una suma infinita
de funciones senos y cosenos que tienen
ciertos pesos verdad y es la idea de las
series de furia y en realidad usamos esa
idea para hallar las fórmulas de estos
coeficientes a hacer o a1 a2 b1 b2 todos
estos coeficientes verdad solamente
utilizando el poder del cálculo integral
verdad sólo utilizamos el poder del
cálculo integral y ahora vamos a usarlo
digamos vamos a usar estas fórmulas de
los coeficientes para el caso de nuestra
onda cuadrada que tenemos justamente
aquí verdad
esta onda cuadrada en particular vamos a
poner que tiene una altura de tres y
quizás lo que hay que notar verdad de
esta onda cuadrada que hemos elegido es
que tiene periodo dos picada
y unidades de tiempo se repite digamos
la función verdad es exactamente igual
en cada intervalo de de longitud 2 pi
muy bien y de hecho la razón por la cual
empezamos con este este intervalo verdad
es que la suma o en realidad todas estas
cuentas se vuelven mucho más simples
cuando tomamos una longitud de dos pi y
en realidad esta es la razón por la cual
empezamos con función coseno y función
seno verdad porque son funciones
justamente que tienen periodo dos y muy
bien entonces con esto además tenemos
que las cuentas son mucho más fáciles ya
tendremos oportunidad después de
generalizar a otros intervalos en el
futuro pero ahora lo que vamos a hacer
es calcular a cero a n b n verdad para
esta onda cuadrada en particular y la
clave aquí es notar que que nuestra onda
tiene un valor de tres de cero a pi
vamos a poner aquí
de 0 a pi y tiene un valor 0 cuando
estamos entre p2p muy bien entonces
vamos a calcular estos valores empecemos
con a 0 a 0 va a ser 1 entre 2 y 1 entre
dos pi por de hecho lo voy a hacer un
poquito explicito verdad porque esta
idea nos va a ayudar a calcular las
otras integrales vamos a calcular la
integral verdad vamos a calcular la
integral de 0 a ti verdad que es el
primer intervalo en donde toma un valor
distinto en nuestra función y luego
vamos a sumar la integral de p2p
entonces tenemos la integral de 0 aquí
de nuestra función
efe verdad es más vamos a dejarlo
simplemente así más la integral de p2p
en nuestra función y por supuesto
integramos con respecto a t muy bien
entonces nuestra función toma un valor 3
de 0 a ti y toma un valor 0 de p2p
entonces en realidad éste
no cuenta este integral vale 0 y sólo
nos queda esta otra integral verdad
entonces esto tendrá que ser 1 / 2 pi
que multiplica a la anti derivada de 3
en este caso sería 3 t evaluada de 0 a
ti verdad entonces esto por supuesto es
3 y verdad sería 1 entre 2 y vamos a
ponerlo así 1 entre 2 pi y vamos a tener
en el numerador 3 y -0 que es
simplemente 3 pi entonces en realidad y
se cancela y tenemos sólo el valor de
tres medios entonces esto vale tres
medios y en realidad esto tiene mucho
sentido porque nosotros dijimos que a
cero es el valor promedio de nuestra
función verdad y tres medios es 1.5 y
aquí tenemos justamente la línea que
corresponde al promedio verdad que es el
valor a cero que es 1.5 o 3 medios
entonces ya tenemos el valor de acero
vamos a ver qué pasa con el valor de a n
vamos a calcular el valor de a n
siguiendo esta fórmula tendremos que es
uno entre pi por la integral de cero a
dos pero ya vimos que decía dos bien en
realidad vale cero verdad porque la
función vale cero entonces cero por
coseno es cero y pues la integral de
cero es cero muy bien así que sólo vamos
a dejar la integral de cero a pi del
valor de nuestra función efe que en este
caso es tres verdad por coseno coseno de
nt
y esto lo integramos con respecto a té
muy bien entonces algo que quizás sería
conveniente hacer es primero sacar este
3 de la integral vamos a sacar el 3 de
la integral y lo ponemos en este
numerador vamos a ponerlo de este lado y
ahora nos preguntamos cuál es una anti
derivada de coseno de nt bueno pues
nosotros sabemos que si derivamos seno
de n te vamos a tener n por el coseno de
nt ya lo hemos hecho en algún otro vídeo
así que multiplicamos por n y dividimos
entre n sólo que dividimos afuera de la
integral verdad entonces aquí lo que
obtendremos es 3 n sobre n verdad que
multiplica a la anti derivada de eneko
seno de emt que es el seno de nt y todo
esto va evaluado de 0 a ti muy bien
entonces tendremos nuevamente 3 dividido
entre n muy bien que multiplica a seno
de n p pero el seno de múltiplos de pies
y si ahora restamos seno de n por 0 que
es 0 el seno de 0 es cero y entonces
tendremos 0 - 0 que es cero por lo que
sea vale cero entonces todo esto vale
cero en realidad los coeficientes a n
valen cero en todos los casos verdad
para cualquier entero n muy bien
entonces si vemos nuestra serie de furia
en realidad todos estos cosenos no van a
aparecer en la serie de furia porque
todos estos coeficientes valen cero está
muy interesante vamos a calcular ahora
bn muy bien vamos a calcular ahora b n b
n pues será siguiendo nuestra fórmula
uno entre pi y otra vez vamos a dejar
solo la integral de cero a ti porque de
p2p vale cero verdad de nuestra función
que en este caso vale tres multiplicando
por él
de nt y esto lo vamos a integrar con
respecto a ti muy bien vamos a no
saltarnos pasos por ahora entonces vamos
a poner aquí que esto vale 1 entre pi
oops salió muy raro eso 1 / p por la
integral de 0 at y de bueno vamos a
sacar de una vez el 3 verdad aquí vamos
a sacar el 3 el 3 que está en color
verde lo sacamos y lo ponemos en el
numerador y vamos a integrar el seno de
nt con respecto a t muy bien y otra vez
pensamos en una anti derivada para el
seno de nt pero nosotros sabemos que si
derivamos coseno de nt tendremos menos
en el seno de nt así que multiplicamos
por menos n y dividimos entre menos voy
a hacerlo con otro color
- n y dividimos entre menos n muy bien
entonces ahora sí que es lo que
tendremos tendremos menos 3 sobre n p
verdad que multiplica a la anti derivada
de menos en el seno de n
que es coseno de nt
y esto lo evaluamos de 0
entonces ya casi estamos llegando al
resultado
esto será otra vez menos 3 sobre n p y
ahora nos preguntamos bueno quien es
coseno de n
bueno vamos a dejarlo así sería evaluar
esto ente igual aquí sería coseno dnp y
luego restamos coseno de n por 0 que es
coseno de 0 y eso siempre es 1 así que
uno puede notar que este valor del
coseno dnp pues dependerá exactamente de
quién sea n por ejemplo esto puede valer
en realidad es el coseno de múltiplos de
pi verdad y el coseno de múltiplos de pi
es 1 o menos 1 en realidad esto depende
de 100 spark o si n es impar verdad
entonces por ejemplo si vamos a vamos a
escribir algo así el valor bn b n tiene
dos valores distintos
vamos a poner bien esto tiene dos
valores distintos uno será si n es par
vamos a poner el primer caso si n es
y el otro caso será si n es impar
entonces pensemos si n estar verdad si
en sparc tendremos por ejemplo el coseno
de dos picos seno de cuatro pick coseno
de seis pi todos éstos valen uno y
entonces tendremos uno menos uno que es
cero que multiplicado por lo que sea
vale cero entonces en realidad este
coeficiente es cero si n es par 07 estar
ahora bien qué pasa si en es impar por
ejemplo el coseno de pi coseno de tres
picos' seno de cinco y todos esos tienen
un valor de menos uno verdad menos 1 - 1
todo esto sería menos 2 todo esto sería
menos 2 y al multiplicarlo por esto
tendríamos bueno menos por menos es más
2 por 36 y tendremos seis dividido entre
n si n es impar así que ya podemos dar
una expresión digamos en un desarrollo
en serie de furia de nuestra onda
cuadrada verdad nuestra onda cuadrada
que tenemos aquí dibujada verdad y esta
onda cuadrada pues lo podríamos escribir
como el valor a cero que nosotros
dijimos que era tres medios que de hecho
es el promedio y luego va a tener puros
términos se nos verdad porque dijimos
que los coeficientes que acompañan al
coche no se canse elaborado en realidad
se hace en cero todos ellos y de los
senos sólo vamos a tener los que tienen
un índice impar verdad porque los que
son pares valen cero es lo que tenemos
aquí vale cero tiene es para entonces el
primer término será seis dividido entre
uno por verdad que multiplica
seno al seno de uno porte que sólo lo
vamos a poner por como t y luego no
agregamos el término par porque vale
cero y tendremos el término que sigue
que es seis dividido entre tres pi por
el seno de 3
no vamos a agregar el término 4 vamos a
seguirnos hacia el término 5 que sería 6
sobre 5 y por el seno de 5 t y así
podemos sumar muchísimos otros términos
verdad de hecho aquí se ve muy bien cuál
es el patrón y ahí tenemos ya nuestro
desarrollo en serie de furia para la
onda cuadrada y en el próximo vídeo
vamos a tratar de visualizar esto